Venezuela has the largest oil reserves
in the world so it comes as a surprise
to son that gasoline has been in short
supply there for years
the shortage has now reached
unsustainable levels and is hitting the
capital Caracas in the middle of a
pandemic without fuel it could be easier
to keep the lockdown regulations but at
what cost this report now from Caracas
here in the Venezuelan capital the
streets are empty despite the fact that
Venezuela has the lowest number of kovat
19 infections in Latin America people
here are adhering strictly to lockdown
rules some say that's partly because of
a severe shortage of gasoline will force
the quarantine whether we like it or not
due to the lack of gasoline you may or
may not agree with staying at home
there's no way of going out without
gasoline economist Rafael Kiros believes
this shortage is due to a lack of
maintenance work on Venezuela's six oil
refineries the US sanctions against the
state oil company since early last year
have made things worse but outside the
capital the gasoline shortage has been
going on for at least six years
Oh since Edison common-rail is the
65,000 barrels of oil currently produced
each day in Venezuela as well as the
import do not cover the gasoline needed
for vehicles which is no less than
180,000 barrels per day right now during
the global pandemic the gasoline
shortages appear to be encouraging
people to stay home but medical
emergencies food distribution and rising
prices are also affected by the lack of
fuel when the lockdown began
Astrid Garcia hoped to be able to offer
food deliveries now that's become
complicated we have to leave home at
10:00 in the evening to wait for the
truck bringing fuel for the next day it
starts pumping gas toward noon and we
leave there at 3:00 or 4:00 in the
afternoon there's only enough gasoline
for 200 motorcycles siento no Medicaid
and para no st. a Mota a black market
for fuel has emerged selling gasoline
well above the official price of under
one cent despite the shortage the
national oil company continues to export
is amusing it is it makes no sense that
while we are suffering from a shortage
of gasoline we're sending 25,000 barrels
of gasoline a day to Cuba the drop in
oil prices is a severe blow to the
Venezuelan economy however low fuel
costs mean imports could alleviate the
current shortage what's needed is a
refining company to turn the oil into
fuel and tankers to transport it
you